jarred my hair looks not done it's not
et with gigi hadid ahead of the 2018
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show she's
literally in her hair and makeup chair
getting ready for the big night she
gushed over the bond the models all
share you feel the sisterhood and you
understand how much we really are so
happy for each other that's a really
nice feeling and that is exciting and
it's also fun to give that feeling to
the girls that are walking for their
first time and to let them know that
it's okay and it can already get easier
their first show in that way of just
realizing they're really all here for
them and for everyone and for each other
Gigi sister Bella is also walking in the
show I mean Bella is such a blessing for
me as a friend and the sister and it's
really nice to be able to in this
industry or in any industry really to
look across the room and have family and
feel like you have a piece of home with
you regardless of where we are in the
world and that's really nice
but really I feel like all of these
girls are my sisters and I know so many
different girls from even like you know
Taylor Hill and I have known each other
since before we were signed models in LA
they like just wanted to like we would
talk about being at the VF show together
and sarah senpai when I did our first
Sports Illustrated to get like that we I
have really different like memories
experiences with every girl and that's a
really nice feeling to just celebrate
them and Gigi's rocking some insane
wings this year I don't have an exact
pound number for you but they're my
biggest wing to my heaviest wings ever
had in the show and there
about three or four feet taller than me
and wide and a unique shape for wings
you'll have to see them but the opposite
of aerodynamic heavy and it's going to
be it's going to be a trek but it's a
really nice feeling to be given the
responsibility of wearing heavy wings
and I just hope I make everyone proud
[Music]